hey Wolfgang we have to that's right
only two more days until Avengers
infinity war with Avengers infinity war
coming out in just a couple of days and
with the overwhelming support that you
all have shown this channel the
stupendous wave and I have prepared a
huge giveaway to give back to our fans
when discussing what we wanted to do for
the giveaway we talked about really we
wanted to give our fans and experience
and when we discussed what a good
experience would be we landed on that
we'd like to give you all the best movie
viewing experience you can get for your
home so when you watch your favorite
movies such as The Avengers and Star
Wars you can feel like you're in a
theater again so with that being said
the stupendous wave and I are giving
away a full surround sound 7 piece
speaker system these speakers are some
of the best of the best I personally
love it they're handmade in Germany and
they're the same speakers that I have
set up in my theater room the speaker
system includes two front speakers with
a sinner channel two subwoofers and two
left and right rear speakers we'll also
be including the Avengers The Avengers
age of Ultron and the latest Star Wars
films all you have to do to enter the
giveaway is subscribe to this channel to
cosmic Wonder subscribe to the
stupendous wave drop a like and leave a
comment below of your favorite superhero
character again I just want to express
how extremely appreciative I am of you
all trying to support me and while I
grow my channel if there's anything
specific that you all would like a video
on you can comment it below whether it's
Marvel DC or anything else related to
superheroes again all you have to do to
enter the contest is be subscribed to
this channel subscribe to the stupendous
wave like this video and leave a comment
below with your favorite superhero the
winner will be chosen at random in a few
weeks thank you so much for watching and
thank you so much for your support
woof woof
[Music]
you